speaking of schools
you know
the the libs are looking at the polls
and they're seeing that
peddling radical sexual theories in
schools doesn't play very well
not only does it not play well in
conservative states it doesn't play well
in liberal states either it turns out
that a whole slow wide spread of voters
not just white voters but black and
hispanic not just republicans but
democrats and liberals too they don't
like it when you try to transgender
their little kids they think that's
weird and so the democrats first have
denied that it's happening
but we know it's happening we've seen it
in virginia and we've seen it in florida
and you've seen the voters come out
and elect republicans in those kind of
places in large part because of these
issues
they see how badly this polls
and they try to deny that it's happening
and they say no we aren't teaching weird
sex stuff to kids and it's really good
that we are there's a new video out
thanks to chris ruffo who's done a great
job on this issue in particular
it shows that the mazzoni center
has just hosted a big conference
on on how important it is to transgender
the kids in schools the matzoni center
has
sex programs full-time staff that teach
sex programs in philadelphia public
schools
all the way up to grade 12 all the way
down to kindergarten the matzoni center
promotes transgenderism and weird sex
stuff to kids in philadelphia schools
grades k through 12.
last year they secured five million
dollars in government contracts here is
uh just a little taste of the sort of
lesson that you would receive at a
matzoni center class or conference i am
rachel simon i use she her pronouns i am
a psychotherapist educator consultant
and author
i run my private practice here in
philadelphia and i am the author of the
every body book which is a
an lgbtq inclusive
um sex ed resource for seven to 12 year
olds and i love that you said that this
this talk specifically was geared
towards teens but you're so right that
sexuality education starts
the minute you're born i mean we have
we're born with bodies these bodies are
cool we want to touch our bodies we're
learning about um privacy and you know
being
sexual in public from a very early age
homophobic and transphobic ideas from
parents can absolutely be a problem
inescapable judgment
yeah bigoted misinformed parents who
have no idea how to talk about gay sex
they're biased if they are religious it
can be very difficult to get into the
conversation with them
it can be really difficult if those
parents aren't radical sexual
revolutionaries like i am who want to uh
not only
uh promote
all sorts of unusual sexual desires and
behaviors among people but also trans
your five-year-olds yeah it can be
really hard and that's why it's so
important that we go into the schools
with government money by the way with
five million dollars in government
contracts to go in there and teach your
kids
how absolutely terrible you are and and
to totally contradict every value you've
ever taught them and to make them like
me an obviously well-adjusted not total
psycho right right that's that's what
she's saying
they're not hiding it
this is not i'm not reading between the
lines she is telling you this she's
saying we hate it when parents
teach their kids traditional religious
values
you raise your kid christian
or jewish or muslim for that matter
we hate that that's bad
so what we do is we go in with with the
parents taxpayer money by the way we go
into the schools and say yeah your
parents are bigoted they're they're
misogynistic they're they're awful
closed-minded
and don't believe what they say believe
what we say thank you parents by the way
for funding my salary yeah we we just go
we go into the schools
and we and we tell kids that they need
to embrace the rainbow
that's what's happening we knew it was
happening
then the libs deny that it's happening
then they tell us it's good that it's
happening but they still deny that it's
happening
and sometimes we need to see it with our
own eyes
there is no
live and let live here
conservatives first impulse very often
is live and let live if you guys want to
do that that's fine but just don't force
it on me however you want to live that's
fine just don't make me do it
throw your hands in the air
there's no neutrality
there is no
well you do you don't yuck yum none of
that
the kids are either going to learn
traditional sexual morality
or radical lgbtq lmnop
trans the kids sexual morality
they will not learn no sexual morality
that woman has a point
when she says that we start to have
questions about our sex not i'm not
saying
erotic questions i'm saying just what is
a boy what is a girl what do boys and
girls mean what is mommy and daddy they
start to have these questions very very
young
people do have questions about their
bodies at a young age and certainly as
they approach puberty they start to have
these questions more and more
and if we spend eight hours of our day
in school when we're little kids then
we're gonna learn things there too we're
gonna learn things among other kids and
with the and we're gonna ask questions
of our teachers and it yes you are gonna
learn that stuff the question is what
are you going to learn what is going to
be taught
it's not even any longer going to be ask
your parents
ask your parents
was a substantive answer what that
answer means is your parents have the
right to inculcate in you a certain
sexual
tradition and understanding but now
that's being contradicted by the left
even even that is considered reactionary
now how do those parents are bigoted and
awful and misogynist they're going to
destroy their kids lives no we have a
responsibility to go into schools
so what is it which one are we you have
to make a choice you can't just be well
do whatever you want
what do you want your kids to be raised
by that psycho in that video or do you
want your kids to be raised in a
more traditional way
if the answer is the latter as i suspect
it is then we need to go in and wield
state power and defund the matsony
center and take away its 5 million in
government contracts and fire lunatics
like that girl in the video and fire
teachers if they teach this kind of
stuff in the schools and pass laws
saying that you can't teach this kind of
stuff in the schools that's the only
thing you can do otherwise you are
giving over the whole culture and the
way your kids are raised to these
weirdos i think it was auron mcintyre i
i've quoted this viral tweet on my show
multiple times now which is
the party that wants to win is always
going to beat the party that just wants
to be left alone
that that is an eternal rule of politics
he's not the first guy to say it but his
version of it went viral on on the
internet
we need to want something we need to
want to win we need to have a
substantive vision of the country if not
if we just want to kind of be left alone
then that lady is
the new mommy that lady is raising your
kids okay
you're seeing it teachers are not hiding
this they're bragging about this
there was a teacher just took to tick
tock we're seeing it thanks to our
friends at libs of tick tock who who
said that although there are laws now
being passed in the country to stop
teachers from inculcating radical sexual
ideology in their young kids her pride
flag is the most important thing in her
classroom
i'm a teacher in a very conservative
state and so sometimes students ask me
why do i have that pride flag
and to me that's the most important part
of my classroom i'm not lgbtq i'm
totally straight married to a man
but i need my students to know that they
are safe and they are loved here without
making a big deal about it without
having like a big conversation
so by having
just that teeny little flag at the front
of my room
i can communicate to them that i support
them and that this is a safe place for
them where they can focus on learning
and that
means everything to me and if a student
has a problem with it then they can find
a different teacher
she's so nice isn't she she just wants
everyone to feel safe and loved do you
think christian students will feel safe
and loved when they see that flag that
flag which means you are wrong
that flag which means your views are not
legitimate that your views are evil and
bigoted
and need to be run out of the public
square do you think the christian how
about the jewish students do you think
the jewish students
the jewish students who take their
religion seriously do you think that
they feel safe and welcome when they see
that flag that flag which says you are
wrong and you are evil and your views
should be run out of town muslim
students do you think
muslim students take this stuff
real seriously do you do there's not
there's not a whole lot of liberalism in
islam like there is in christianity and
judaism do you think that
or like they're i should say like there
can be in christianity in judaism
obviously the more orthodox christians
and jews do not have a lot of liberalism
in their in their religion do you think
the muslims feel safe and welcome when
the pride flag is there saying you are
you are wrong you are evil you are
bigoted your culture is disgusting
do you think that i don't think they do
no i give the teacher credit because
she's being honest
in that yes to her and to so many of
these re revolutionaries
the pride flag is the most important
thing because
all human conflict ultimately is
theological
and
beyond reading writing and arithmetic
when we educate people we're teaching
them the most basic things the most
important things who we are what we are
what does it mean to live the good life
what are we aiming at what should we do
what is virtue so of course the flag
actually is the most important thing
more so than the whiteboard and the
abacus that's for sure
because it's getting to the very root of
education what is education for
now i don't think education should be
aimed at instilling pride in people i
think i think pride is a sin and the
queen of all sins and pride goes before
destruction and a haughty spirit before
a fall and i think that the sexual
pathologies that the the pride flag
represents are not particularly helpful
to people and i don't think it's very
helpful to tell seven-year-old boys that
they're actually little girls
i don't think that helps them she might
sincerely believe that that will help
them that might be her deeply held
religious view
and that contradicts the religious views
of the christians and the jews and the
muslims and you know what folks
the aoc version of religious liberty
where you just you should be able to do
whatever you want that's not that's an
incoherent answer
because you can't simultaneously teach
both you cannot simultaneously teach
boys or boys and girls or girls
and boys can be girls and girls can be
boys those are mutually exclusive
those are contradictory statements
you have to pick one
the christians the jews and the muslims
they believe the first one
the liberals and the secularists and the
leftists and the progressives they
believe the latter one
those are religious it's an actual
religious conflict it's not just
political or cultural and we've got to
pick and we in the political human
community have every right to pick and
we have every right to settle certain
religious questions
our declaration of independence says
that we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal and endowed by their creator with
certain unalienable rights that is a
religious
statement
about god that is the predicate for our
country
if you
if you do not believe in that
then you do not have a much of a place
in america that is a limit to the
religious liberty of america as so many
people have pointed out religious
liberty in america does not mean freedom
from religion it might mean freedom of
religion but it doesn't mean freedom
from religion
and religious liberty is not even the
point of the first amendment by the way
when we talk about the establishment
clause of the first amendment
that doesn't mean that there's absolute
total religious liberty this is one of
the most misunderstood clauses of the
entire constitution the reason that the
framers of the constitution did not
establish a church at the national level
was in large part because the states
already had established churches they
already had certain states most mostly
were episcopalian but there were other
establishments as well that persisted
for decades after the constitution
so yeah that's what religious freedom
really means we need to put limits here
we need to use the law to do it we need
to tell that weirdo teacher hey take
that flag down or get out of the
classroom oh that's the most important
thing in your classroom okay well then
find another job because this job ain't
for you i'm glad you liked that video i
liked it too i liked being here with you
to be seen by you if you want to get
more videos you've got to subscribe ring
the click the like the bell the
subscribe whatever you got to do
subscribe get the notifications head on
over to apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play wherever you get your audio
podcast subscribe leave a five star
review we'll see you next time
[Music]